the philosopher Eric Davis refers to
humans as sparks and crackling with
being and intuition right there is that
sneaking suspicion that there is more to
us that nature allows you know the human
mind lives in the liminal zone it is not
bound by time by space by distance there
is a natural intuition to live in these
spaces of dream these spaces between so
to speak we visit these zones when we're
asleep every night you know the dream is
real when you're in it Chris Nolan says
in Inception
Noam Chomsky talks about a psychic
continuity right when we watch a piece
of film that is 24 still images per
second and then you introduce editing
and cutting and cross-cutting across
time across space yet psychic continuity
links the events together and creates a
contiguous experience the human mind has
no problem orienting its awareness
towards dimensions in which time is no
longer linear we enter these virtual
realities were really their real
virtuality
and we believed them we actively
metabolized belief we become immersed
the mind unplugs from the body and is
not bound in any capacity in that
eventually I think is where we're gonna
go with all of our virtual reality
technologies we're going to move towards
universes
own construction as mckenna says we're
going to move into spaces in which
reality is going to be a relative term
where people might suffer from
relativity sickness the way that they
suffer from a DD today it's a wild idea
I think that's where we're heading
you